hi there  listen to me listen before you speak  listen get the language in you never has  it been easier to listen to the language  to get our brain cells attuned to the  language we've got whether it be the  airpods or whatever you use and there's  an abundance of you know on my iPad I  can find radio stations Netflix so much  stuff to listen to but you and listening  really is the sort of most powerful  thing you can do I think reading is  better for vocabulary acquisition but  listening is where you drive that  language into your brain listen to  things that are interesting to you but  you got to have a strategy you can't  listen to things that you don't  understand you have to have access to a  transcript and I talk about listening  and the power of listening uh as one of  the secrets to language learning but you  want to get all of my 10 secrets so go  to my blog the linguist.com and get my  10 secrets to language learning start  listening and learning bye for now